hi everyone I'm Feliz Frankel I'm a
science photographer and instructor here
at MIT I've been working with
researchers for more than 20 years
finding exciting ways to photograph some
pretty amazing research and to visually
communicate that research for journal
articles presentations and other sorts
of communication now before we start our
course I thought it would be helpful to
go over a few things first just a little
bit about what we're trying to
accomplish we'd like to introduce you to
a new way to think about images of your
research a new approach in photographing
science and engineering whether you're
in research or just someone interested
in photographs you will find these
approaches relevant to your own everyday
photography if you're photographing
small objects or desktop setups or even
those quick images you make of your
favorite dishes that you post online
it's really about making pictures that
are more than good enough most of the
photographs in the course will be on the
macro level close-up photography for
items measuring somewhere between 1 to
10 centimeters we're not going to be
discussing microscopic imaging although
the principles you'll be learning here
will still be relevant now what do I
mean by new approaches it's about taking
a step back and trying to see your
material for the first time thinking
about how best to show what it is to
someone else to communicate with images
to bring clarity to your photographs and
an understanding of how to communicate
what is probably some pretty beautiful
and interesting stuff and in the process
you learn to see your material in new
ways and perhaps think about it
differently and this is what I would
really personally love to make happen to
eventually look at the world in a
completely different way I'd like to
encourage you to fully participate in
the course by doing the photographic
assignments as you know we
learn so much more when we try it
ourselves so we've kept the assignments
straightforward and reasonable to
accomplish in a limited time span and
finally I want to encourage you to relax
in many ways making pictures is about
playing and experimenting it doesn't
have to be perfect every time and in
fact I often learn the most from my
mistakes so just have fun and enjoy
yourself we look forward to learning
with you and to introduce you to new
approaches in seeing your work